hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen dpa herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich google mich heute
weil das hier der youtuber macht und ich
bin auch nur noch 15 deswegen hey was
soll man leichter wenn ihr mögt
wahrscheinlich habe ich mir wieder
gerade zehn millionen neuer fallende
gemacht ich bin gut drauf weil ich habe
gerade eine prüfung gehabt die lief 1,3
das heißt 20 plätze sind schon mal 1,3
schriftlich er 15 das heißt der
bettdecke doku werden dafür geht meine
karriere den bach runter nicht stinke
hat nach scheiße wie ihr seht schon wir
befinden uns hier auf google ich habe
schon konkreter eingegeben und dann ist
das immer noch gut drauf ich bin ich
befinde mich auf google habe schon
konkreter eingegeben wir googeln heute
einfach mal mich selbst und zwar wenn
ich glaube schon kommst da hingehe werde
schon noch vor es ist eigentlich auf gut
glück was was ist wenn ich jetzt auf gut
das ist auch derzeit mir die glaube ich
die erste seite an irgendwie oder so es
gibt hier die auswahlmöglichkeiten
contractor alter kong crafter command
conquer entwicklung konkreter shop wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise auf kontraste
alter eingebe steht hier auch hier steht
sogar mein geburtsdatum wie altes kaum
crafter congo after steckbrief promi
geburtstage wollte mich verklagt ein ich
bin spaß der hier vom pc sitzt ich hasse
das wort romy ein paar videos hier dann
ist ja wundervoll so wenig als
contractor shop ein g bekommt der luca
shop.com minister
wenn ich einfach luca bei google
eingeben traf dann luka direkt main
kanal alter als erstes suchergebnis für
den fucking namen von mir ich kann für
craft auch noch mit ihren geben ich
glaube bei wikipedia habe ich keinen
beitrag weil ich das 10.000 mal
abgegeben wieso denn ich bin im let's
play wikipedia geschichte und
popularität der begriff let us play
blablabla hier bin ich ich könnte heulen
wieso bin ich denn bei wikipedia drin
aber ich sehe schon hier ich habe kein
wikipedia-artikel weil das habe ich
immer abgelehnt weil das haben irgendwie
ja
will ich einfach irgendwie nicht was man
halt noch sieht es shop buch von crafter
luca was ist denn wenn der controller
ist ein allesklar.com kraft als tot
konkret das dom kraft das dorf
kontraktes illuminati google und
schleift einer tage oder warum wir jetzt
gegen gegner bei mir grad auf der
persönlichen ebene sind bisschen negativ
eingestellt das frage ich mich grad der
mann inneren von kopf weil kraft das tod
kommt ein video ja okay das war dieses
war lied von lukas der rapper ist das
glaube ich haben wir komme ist so
kompakt dass tore von crafter ist tot
und hofft dass tod direkt tot
ja das ist ja da war ich wohl tot jetzt
mache ich mal konkret als dumm was kommt
da 8 oder kommt ein dings christ hiervon
teste dich bist du so bist du so doof
wie luca wer macht denn so ein quiz
apropos ich habe schon übel lang atteste
nicht mehr gemacht
wollt ihr mal wieder testen ich dann
spam in die kommentare teste dich und
wenn wir 5000 kommentare haben die
tester dich halten dann kommt vielleicht
nicht oder nicht ich hab ich bin einfach
gut drauf weil diese fucking prüfung
hinter mir habe und jetzt habe ich zwei
wochen frei hammer cora ich weiß jetzt
um eine flasche gegen die wand so
glücklich bin ich gerade trinkgeld sein
schloss vitello
ich hab gerade vergessen wie lange
dieses verfügte wasser hier schon steht
seht ihr das sieht man wahrscheinlich
gar nicht nur dass er meine hose hier
sieht man ich habe gerade alles
ausgespuckt und bin jetzt nass ich hole
mal kurz c war ein paar sekunden später
okay leute spass und kein thema mehr im
holz deswegen habe ich es einfach eine
boxershort genommen und das ganze hier
sauber gewischt hat ist eine boxershort
tatsächlich dass ich meine freunde es
gibt so viele normale youtuber die
machen tolle videos mit ihren
freundinnen mit ihren tollen sport wegen
zeigen wie viel geld sie verdienen und
spitzer nicht spucke wasser aus was ist
schon voll lange in meinem zimmer steht
und kotzte dabei halt und warum ich
stelle die frage so oft was findet ihr
an meinem content toll es ist auch jetzt
noch von filmen das nicht gerade auch
sehr schön sind diese bilder die hier
eingeblendet werden bei contractors dom
das schädigt behinderter guck ich dumm
da gucke ich auch um tatsächlich ist das
video mit instagram kommentare von mir
ich habe ich habe schon wieder so viele
dumme kommentare auf dem handy
wollt ihr dazu mein video ich habe
einerseits die video idee dumme
kommentare zu dem video mein neues auto
was ich vor ein paar tagen hochgeladen
habe dass kein neues auto ist aber dann
kam ultra viele kommentare zu
unterhalten wieder normal instagram
kommentare weil wieder ultra viele dumme
instagram kommt heraus gekommen
wollt ihr das zeigt mit einem like ich
google jetzt weiter kaufkraft dass
dohmen crafter stone hatten wir schon
wenn ich konkret das dorf eingebe kommen
wieder tests und eigentlich von dem
beluga ist zu dumm um zu essen
ja wenn ich mir dieses video weiter an
schauer sehen wir da ist dieser typ ist
irgendwie apfelmus und das ganze video
geht fünf minuten 30 wollt ihr ein video
wo ich nur auf dieses video reagiere
dann haben wir auch noch konkreter ist
illuminati da was zum fig seid ihr seid
ihr komplett todes von crafter komplotts
das name ist luca luca luka vier
buchstaben fiat auf vier buchstaben 4 +
4 gleich acht das griechische wort für
acht ist auch freunde wie kann sowas 166
1000 aufrufe haben was zum fig was
passiert wenn ich bei google einfach mal
luca ist luca ist dumm schwul tod den
neue kämpfe ich meine ist es nur bei mir
so oder auch wenn ich nahm von anderen
usern ein gdp ist tot
wieso kommen bei dem so positive ok
todes letztlich so positiv aber bei mir
kommt das nicht dumm bin
doch tot schwul dominate kevin rudd also
ich glaube wenn ich jetzt nicht gerade
die 1,3 in der prüfung zurück bekommen
hätte würde ich gerade meine flasche
gegen die wand boxen und danach die hin
rutschen was ich halt auch schon gemacht
habe an dieser stelle bendig aber auch
das heutige video meine damen und herren
soll gar nicht mal so lang gehen ich
habe einfach gesehen und von anderen
usern gesagt bekommen junge luca wieso
machst du eigentlich nicht das dass du
dich mal googles die man dafür perfekt
auf deinem content passen und deswegen
ich mach das
ich habe in diesem video glaube ich drei
neue video vorschläge genannt nämlich
einmal kommentare zu meinem neuen auto
dann böse instagram kommentare und auf
dass luca video reagieren die lukas du
dummes zum essen was wir uns jetzt
angesehen haben wenn ihr die videos
haben wollt schreibt man die kommentare
dann werden die in den nächsten tagen
wochen kommen habe ich auf jeden fall
bock drauf und wir sehen uns im nächsten
video wieder reinschauen